big daddy made the right call patrick my
home always makes it look so easy you
guys
how is anybody left open when you got
patrick home i don't know
very open indeed very well done kansas
city chiefs we welcome you to cbs this
morning
we have a big announcement on the
vaccine front we'll talk to dr ashish
jaw on that in just a moment but
right now we want to start with millions
of americans going to extraordinary lens
to celebrate thanksgiving and many
are waiting in lines for hours here's a
look at this huge line for testing
outside denver
people hope they will be safer with
relatives if they test negatives but the
experts say
that is not a sure thing there are also
massive lines for giveaways at food
banks and we're seeing scenes like this
play out nationwide and despite the
pandemic airports are still
packed as millions take flights that's
despite dire wings from health experts
people could unknowingly infect their
loved ones over the holiday
chris van cleave is at reagan national
airport outside washington chris good
morning
well good morning on the same day the
cdc told americans not to travel that
very morning southwest's ceo told us
while the airline was seeing an increase
in cancellations
it was being outpaced by new bookings
you can look around reagan national
airport you can see
it is not the holiday season we're used
to they expect travel air travel in
particular to be down 50 to 60 percent
but that still means millions of people
are going to fly or
drive to see relatives this thanksgiving
and that has health experts
very worried about the potential of a
deadly coveted surge
just in time for christmas from packed
gates at phoenix sky harbor airport
this feels dangerous to long lines at
lax
and this traffic at chicago o'hare
americans are on the move
covet or not i'm like there's a lot more
people here than i thought would be here
more than one million people were
screened to tsa checkpoints on friday
nearly a million more on saturday
despite the cdc urging americans not to
travel for the thanksgiving holiday
it's a family necessity trip you know i
take the necessary precautions
aaa estimates up to 50 million americans
will travel for thanksgiving
down from last year but the holiday
comes as the u.s
sets daily records for coronavirus cases
for some that means getting coveted
tests before spending time with their
loved ones
i'm probably going to get tested again
once i get back to make sure i'm good
but experts warn testing could provide a
false sense of security because of
kovit's up to 14 day incubation period
two or three days after a negative test
you could become contagious even before
showing symptoms
that's why neil siegel a public health
professor canceled his thanksgiving
plans
when i was weighing the option to travel
back to california to see my parents
both of whom are elderly and have
chronic health conditions i realized
that the potential risk that i posed to
them in traveling was probably too great
and of course i wouldn't really be able
to live with myself if i do that i
brought
copic 19 into their home
and new this morning united airlines is
announcing it's expanding
its covid testing efforts to its houston
hub it will offer mail-in
coveted tests to passengers flying to 10
caribbean and latin american countries
that's in addition to the testing
efforts
that united has rolled out in new york
in san francisco
tony all right chris thank you very much